hablamos del asesinato de María Belén
Bernal estrangulada presuntamente en una
sede policial las manos de su pareja un
Teniente que se encuentra prófugo y
apunta a convertirse en uno de los
rostros más emblemáticos de la violencia
de género en Ecuador tras causar gran
alarma en el país por las circunstancias
de este caso este caso también ha
golpeado al seno de la policía de
Ecuador al mismo tiempo hay una docena
miembros de la policía a los que se les
ha abierto expedientes por haber
contribuido a este hecho ya sea por
acción o por omisión sale vamos a Mayra
tiritallas coordinadora de acciones
legales de surcuna Gracias Mayra por
estar con nosotros en directo América de
Francia 24 muy buena mañana de martes
hablemos y demos a los televidentes de
nuestra audiencia primero que nada una
actualización de este caso
Mayra buenos días Me escuchas Buenos
días le escucho sí quisiéramos primero
que nada pues hablar de una
actualización de este caso que es lo
último que se ha sabido sobre el
asesinato de la señora Bernal perfecto
efectivamente bueno como este
conocimiento popular
la muerte de María Belén es un caso de
femicidio porque sucede directamente en
las instalaciones policiales a mano de
un Teniente de hecho era un instructor
de policía el teniente Cáceres lo que
sucedió de manera actual en el caso es
que efectivamente el responsable el
presunto responsable del caso que es
este Teniente sigue fugado completamente
del país y se han iniciado como procesos
penales en contra de otros presuntos
responsables inicialmente se ha iniciado
un proceso penal en contra de otra
Cadete que se encontraba ese mismo día
en el mismo lugar también entendemos que
se han iniciado como otras acciones
legales en contra de otros Cadetes que
también estaban en el recinto policial y
que sin embargo no
auxiliaron de manera oportuna María
Belén eso en cuanto a los procesos
penales ahora en cuanto a los la
situación política este fin de semana
efectivamente el ministro Carrillo fue
destituido de su cargo en gran medida
debido al manejo del caso directamente
de María Belén hasta la actualidad el
día de hoy la asamblea se va a reunir va
a conocer en pleno nuevamente en la
situación de María Belén va a estar
directamente su madre y vamos a ver un
poco Cuáles van a ser los siguientes
pasos políticos que van a tomar
directamente a partir del caso en contra
de la violencia contra las mujeres
también digamos Mayra que hay un nuevo
ministro del interior en Ecuador Juan
Zapata tomó posición del cargo y dijo
que su misión era digamos de alguna
manera reestructurar la policía tras ese
caso se han visto alguna estructuración
reestructuración Mejor dicho de la
policía en lo que lleva en el cargo qué
anuncios ha dicho el nuevo ministro
bueno efectivamente hasta ahora
solamente ha sido como este primero esta
alerta fundamental de poder encontrar a
Cáceres en primer lugar Y en segundo
lugar bueno ya Carrillo lo que hizo
inicialmente fue cambiar directamente de
director a una mujer como directora de
formación directamente de la policía
estos han sido como las principales
anuncios también entiendo que hay lugar
donde se encontraba María Belén y donde
vivían directamente los policías que le
llamaban como un castillo de gracell ahí
el anuncio directamente de que este
lugar se va a demoler y se va a hacer
como otro lugar transparente y que en
este lugar transparente más bien va a
ser para el tema de promoción de
derechos eso es un poco los anuncios que
existen hasta ahora todavía otro tipo de
acciones no se han tomado creemos que
eso es lo más urgente no creo que decir
se puede decir muchísimas cosas pero ya
efectivamente tomar acciones concretas
es lo que debería realizarse
Mayra como ocurre un hecho como este
dentro de una de un edificio policial no
es un poco como impactante que estas
cosas ocurran dentro de la policía
precisamente
claro efectivamente para nosotros nos
parece que el caso de María Belén es la
punta del iceberg no nosotros tenemos
una estadística de 206 mujeres
muertas por razones de género Víctimas
de violencia feminicida del en lo que va
del año hasta el 3 de septiembre sin
contar directamente el caso de María
Belén y claro creo que lo que hace el
caso de María beléndez Mostrar esta
punta del iceberg de este gran problema
del femicidio en Ecuador de la falta de
acción de la falta de política pública y
no solamente de la falta de acción y la
falta de política pública por parte del
Estado para prevenir y erradicar la
violencia sino como también el estado se
vuelve perpetrador de esta violencia hay
que recordar que por ejemplo para
nosotros para la Ley Orgánica de
prevenir y erradicar la violencia contra
las mujeres la Policía Nacional cumple
un rol fundamental porque la Policía
Nacional estas acciones y estas medidas
urgentes además de este órgano de apoyo
auxilio directamente para la función
judicial en los casos de violencia
entonces Claro si es que ellos son los
que van a hacer esta primera línea de
atender y justamente son estas mismas
personas quienes terminan dentro de un
recinto policial matando directamente a
María Belén está completamente
deslícitamente es legítida daba su labor
directamente como policía en este rol
fundamental de protección entonces Claro
que se merece acciones concretas de
tutoriales presupuestos claros entre
otras medidas
Mayra ante este asesinato también eh
Pues han salido muchísimas personas a
las calles en protesta digamos para
exigir y la justicia para exigir la
verdad que han logrado durante estos
días de protestas en las calles
concretamente también el colectivo
feminista
bueno Está convocada también para el
primero de octubre una gran marcha
también nacional en relación al caso en
relación
por ahora lo que efectivamente se ha
logrado ha sido directamente el
posicionamiento del caso inicialmente en
segundo lugar creo que la búsqueda no
creo que tenemos un alto índice de
mujeres desaparecidas